alors peut-on généraliser cet exemple de
copenhague à d'autres villes d'europe
c'est la question que je vais poser à
karima delli
bonjour bonjour karima delli vous êtes
députée européenne membre du groupe des
verts vous êtes coordinatrice de la
commission transports et vous venez de
rendre un rapport qui s'appelle mobilité
urbaine durable qui a été voté en
commission et qui attend donc le 2
décembre d'être votée en seigneur voilà
quand vous voyez l'exemple de copenhague
et on voit bien 350 km de pistes
cyclables
donc là on voit bien qu'il ya quand même
eu un effort de fait 14 millions d'euros
qui ont été investi là-dedans le
chauffage urbain les toits verts est-ce
que c'est généralisable à toutes les
villes d'europe
alors oui toutes les villes devrait
tendre vers ce modèle mais sauf qu'il
faut rappeler que copenhague a fait un
choix politique important qui datent pas
de quelques années il faut vous il faut
attendre le lendemain notamment de la
crise pétrolière ou copenhague décidé de
vraiment sortir de sa dépendance au
pétrole dès les années soixante dix et
soixante dix il ya vraiment une volonté
politique de dire le pétrole il faut en
sortir
donkey mise vous l'avez vu dans le vôtre
reportage sur le chauffage urbain
il va alimenter l'ensemble de la ville
et aussi de la mobilité douce et
notamment copenhague aujourd'hui elles
se disputent un petit peu la place avec
amsterdam comme la capitale européenne
du vélo parce que le vélo
oui c'est une industrie aussi qui crée
énormément de deux d'emplois mais
surtout il ya une volonté de tout de
suite faire ce nouveau modèle de ville
où on s'adapte plus aux besoins des
citoyens qu'aux besoins qui a été trop
aujourd'hui utilisée dans les années 70
jusqu'à présent autour de la voiture
donc on change le modèle eh oui ce
modèle est possible de le mettre en
oeuvre a dans d'autres villes mais
encore faut-il de vallans de volonté
politique mais surtout de mesures très
fortes et c'est ce que porte notamment
mon rapport
donc moi ce que ce qui m'intrigue c'est
qu'on voit bien aussi qu'il ya des fonds
14 millions d'euros à investir en fait
chaque année pour créer ces circulations
douces pour améliorer le réseau etc
est ce que dans un contexte contraint
comme on le voit aujourd'hui en termes
budgétaires on est dans la capacité de
faire ce virage est donc de permettre en
fait une
un peu plus douces ou des circulations
plus douce à nos concitoyens alors ça
revient moins cher d'investir dans la
mobilité douce mais que d'avoir cette ce
que moi j'appelle de cette mobilité
subie et non choisie aujourd'hui le fait
qu'on ait une pollution et les pics de
pollution dans les différentes villes
coûte rien qu'en termes de santé
publique
plus de 700 milliards d'euros +
printemps milliards d'euros et les 100
milliards d'euros- à l'europe au niveau
européen au niveau européen la pollution
la pollution la pollution c'est ce que
dit l'onu c'est la maladie du 21e siècle
parce que notre parcours européen de
voitures ses 55% du diesel qu'il faut
sortir aussi de cette question du désert
qui va être aussi un des grands débats
qu'on va avoir durant le rapport le 2
décembre
mais il faut mettre en évidence
réellement qu' il n'y a pas que la
voiture vous savez en europe 50 % des
déplacements on prend sa voiture juste
pour faire moins de 5 km et tous les
trois quarts des trois quarts des deux
autres déplacements se font avec la
voiture donc il faut aujourd'hui
renverser la donne changer de modèle sur
les deux modèles ça veut pas dire non
plus de pointer ceux qui n'ont pas le
choix donc il faut faire en sorte que la
mobilité de demain
ce soit un droit fondamental mais ce que
ça accessible à tout le monde
voilà le problème c'est que j'entends
bien c'est effectivement une belle idée
et on se dit pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'irait pas là dessus demain pourquoi
pas maintenant c'est comment on finance
a alors très simplement
vous savez en europe il ya ce qu'on
appelle une taxe poids lourd alors on ne
dit pas taxe poids lourds ont dit
eurovignette et ben l'eurovignette une
grande partie d'un certain pourcentage
va aller dans la mobilité urbaine
durable
on a un plan s'appelle en latex fois
l'eau pour l'instant par exemple en
france on n'est pas mise en oeuvre
n'allez pas encore mises en oeuvre mais
dès janvier l'europe va légiférer sur
l'eurovignette hawks et la même chose
donc la france devra prendre en compte
notamment la taxe poids lourds dont une
partie de cette taxe qui est quand même
devra être affectée devra être affectée
la mobilité urbaine durable
on peut regretter qu'en france justement
nous sommes le 25e pays sur 28 qui n'a
pas de fiscalité écolo alors que c'est
un manque à gagner 1 la taxe poids
lourds
l'écotaxe comme on dit c'est plus de 1
milliard d'euros avec 1 milliard d'euros
qui étaient fléchés sur des projets de
développement
urbain durable mais on se souvient
effectivement c'était toute polémique
avec la bretagne notamment et les
bonnets rouges qui avaient détruit
quelques portiques voilà donc ça va
c'est juste un des outils il ya d'autres
outils énormément de ville met en place
des péages urbains on le voit ce qui se
passe à londres
une partie de ces recettes va être
affecté dans la mobilité urbaine durable
et en plus il ya le plan juncker le plan
young alors le plan de relance en fait
le 315 milliards d'euros voilà le plus
fameux plan doivent normalement fléchés
sur ossus durable et donc pour la
première fois dans ce plan nous avons
une link ez bien investissements dans la
mobilité durable
donc on a les financements maintenant il
faut la volonté politique m'a parfois
les certaines villes où certaines
régions en europe préfère investir sur
la route que sont les alternatives qui
est une bêtise absolue parce que un
c'est à mon cas gagner notamment en
termes d'infrastructures durables et
mais se trouve surtout c'est sur le dos
de la santé des citoyens
aujourd'hui on a que la question de la
mobilité a des conséquences terribles
sur l'urgence sanitaire parce qu'on sait
par exemple que le diesel ça va ça
provoque plus de 400 mille décès
prématurés en europe donc il fait on
sait anticiper les vous aviez d'ailleurs
pris position sur le diesel gates
données
les constructeurs européens qui ont
trafiqué leurs véhicules de toutes
sortes en fait à ce qu'il rentre dans
les clous de la législation européenne
quelques mots là-dessus rapidement
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre en fait à
ce que l'europe et a fortiori les états
sévisse contre ces constructeurs moi je
trouve que c'est un véritable scandale
puisque il ya une complicité organisé
les états membres était au courant la
commission européenne était au courant
de l'ensemble de ces fraudes
on a menti aux citoyens pourquoi pas ce
qu'on leur a dit acheter ce genre de
véhicule c'est un diesel mais les profs
alors que ce n'est pas vrai on n'est pas
propre
troisième chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
faut du contrôle et de la transparence
que c'est pour ça que nous demandons
nous le groupe des verts une véritable
enquête parlementaire pour faire toute
la lumière et la transparence sur sur ce
dossier voilà merci beaucoup karima
delli vous avoir éclairé sur cette
question pour nous c'est fini cette
semaine vous retrouverez à mettre psg la
semaine prochaine à très vite sur les
chaînes parlementaires ciao